revenons à présent sur ce que l'on
appelle désormais le scandale de
l'amiante hier la justice parlait de
faute inexcusable aujourd'hui les
chiffres donnent le vertige entre 50000
et 100000 personnes qui pourraient être
touchées par un cancer romual venant
jean-claude paniz y est l'une des
victimes de l'amiante son histoire un
cancer suivi d'une greffe de poumons une
maladie professionnelle pendant plus de
dix ans ce retraité de renault véhicules
industriels à vénissieux a testé des
plaquettes de frein en amiante
aujourd'hui il porte plainte pour faute
inexcusable contre les dirigeants de
l'entreprise et je trouvais rapport
toujours qu'on connaît de m'adonner il
est de 1981 mai 1972 et donc si expliqué
que donc les dangers de l'amiante mais
qui n'ont jamais été diffusés au
personnel les tribunaux comme celui de
valence y lire encore voient affluer les
cas liés à l'amiante en france 3000
victimes ont demandé réparation face au
comportement de leurs employeurs du
privé comme par exemple les chantiers de
l'atlantique ou encore du public comme
la faculté de jussieu
le fonds d'indemnisation prévues par la
loi n'a pas encore été créée la justice
elle pointe les fautes inexcusables et
indemnise au coup par coup il a quand
même quelques raisons d'être un peu
inquiet parce que ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que le montant cette indemnisation
d'un tribunal à l'autre varie dans un
ordre de grandeur de rats à 5 des
indemnisations dont le montant a
malheureusement exploser car les experts
par le d'hécatombe entre 50000 et cent
mille français vont mourir d'ici 20 ans
à cause de l'amiante
ça va augmenter
le nombre de cancers liés à l'amiante
vont augmenter de façon certaine au
moins jusqu'à 2 pendant les 20 à 30
prochaines années
parce que l'effet de l'exposition à
l'amiante est différée dans le temps
l'amiante responsables de 80% des
tumeurs de la plèvre de 5 à 15 % des
futurs cancers du poumon une véritable
bombe à retardement